Друзі, всім привіт! Ну, що ж, сьогодні спробую, як навчаються
автомеханіки у Німеччині. Професійно-технічна освіта у ФРН -
одна з найкращих у Європі. Давайте з’ясуємо, як вона організована.
Зараз я  навчатиму Михайла, як бути автоелектриком.
Так, ця штука класно виглядала на стендапі, однак електрозварювання
навряд чи мені хтось зараз доручить.
Гаразд. Що будемо робити?
Треба правильно під’єднати кабель.
Добре зробив?
Так, добре!
Чудово!
Отакий урок автоелектромеханіки від Амера Аль Хафаджі - підмайстра
на станції технічного обслуговування автомобілів у місті Бонн.
А це вже вчитель самого Амера - Крістоф фон Цедтвіц,
власник автомайстерні та керівник виробничої практики.
Практикант за кермом, а шеф з іншими робітниками заштовхують
автівку, що вже не їде своїм ходом. Завдання для підмайстра на сьогодні наступне:
Оцей патрубок забору повітря розірвався. Треба все прочистити,
поставити нові ущільнювачі та прикріпити новий патрубок.
Моєму підмайстру цікаво шукати, де поломка, в чому її причини.
Професійно-технічна освіта в Німеччині буває двох видів.
Перший - це навчання в училищах з перевагою теоретичних занять
в аудиторії. Практичні навички при цьому здобувають у майстернях
в самих навчальних закладах або під час короткої практики на виробництві.
Наш герой Амер обрав другий різновид професійного навчання.
Це дуальна система: одночасне навчання і робота. Вперше такий
принцип професійної підготовки  зафіксований у документах у 1897 році.
У 1969 році Закон про професійне навчання
дав вирішальний поштовх дуальному професійному навчанню в Німеччині.
Роботодавці найбільше цінують спеціалістів, які освоїли професію за цією системою.
Зараз я знімаю старі ущільнювачі, а потім ці місця, де вони
були закріплені, треба очистити.
А скільки триває твоє навчання тут?
Загалом три з половиною роки. Це вже мій останній рік.
Амер навчається на найпопулярнішу технічну професію
серед молодих чоловіків у Німеччині - на автомеханіка.
Друге місце за популярністю - ІТ- спеціалісти, третє -
технік електроніки. Молоді жінки найчастіше ідуть навчатися
на офіс-менеджерок, медпрацівниць і менеджерок роздрібної торгівлі.
А чи можна грошей заробити під час навчання?
Так, можна ще й заробляти, на третій рік навчання я отримую 750 євро на місяць.
Зарплатня збільшується з кожним роком навчання. У перший рік Амер
отримував 600 євро. Загалом же мінімальна ставка для здобувачів
профтехосвіти у ФРН з 2020 року становить 515 євро у перший рік навчання.
Один день на тиждень Амер відвідує теоретичні заняття
у професійно-технічному училищі у Кельні. 70% практичних знань
він здобуває в автомайстерні, 30% теорії - в аудиторіях училища.
Стати підмайстром на німецькому підприємстві можуть і громадяни інших країн.
Я приїхав з Іраку. Я вже 5 років у Німеччині. Спочатку я вчив німецьку.
Потім я протягом шести місяців проходив вступну кваліфікацію
на заводі "Форд". І вже потім почав тут професійне навчання.
Визначитися з майбутньою спеціальністю випускникам шкіл
та всім охочим допомагають спеціалізовані Інтернет-портали.
Один із них - AzubiTV, такий собі телеканал від учнів профосвіти,
де вони у відеороликах самі розповідають про своє навчання.
Спочатку працювати з м’ясом для мене було незвично, однак з часом я звик.
Як механіку-монтажниці систем опалювання мені треба проводити
обслуговування обладнання і усувати несправності або інсталювати всю установку.
Це приносить задоволення: працювати надворі цілий день
з колегами. Я можу робити кладку, бетонувати канали, штукатурити стіни, класти плитку.
Наразі дуальна модель професійно-технічної освіти у ФРН пропонує
навчання на щонайменше 330 спеціальностей. Приватні й державні
підприємства, маленькі фірми й великі корпорації, зокрема, 2019 року
надали 580 тисяч місць для навчання. Заявки на них подали 525 тисяч охочих.
Заявку варто подавати безпосередньо на підприємство, яке
розмістило вакансію.У пакеті необхідних документів -
сертифікати про проходження практики, наприклад, під час
навчання у школі, рекомендаційні листи, резюме, шкільний атестат.
Для окремих підприємств середній бал в атестаті доволі важливий.
Інші приділяють цьому меншу увагу.
Для мене шкільний атестат не грає вирішальної ролі, для мене важлива
сама особистість. Чи обрала людина таке навчання, бо їй це до вподоби,
вона хоче це робити, навчитися працювати руками з механікою,
двигунами, автомобілями? Чи вона просто шукає місце будь-де,
аби отримати яку-небудь освіту.
Власники підприємств не зобов’язані законом надавати місця
для навчання. Втім, наприклад, для такого гіганта, як BMW,
це необхідність, бо треба готувати нове покоління висококваліфікованих
працівників. Крістоф фон Цедтвіц має лише одне місце для підмайстра,
однак для нього це професійне визнання.
Адже Промислова палата, яка організовує і контролює
фінальний іспит учня, вже перевірила і визнала спеціалістів
його СТО достатньо кваліфікованими для передачі своїх знань іншим.
Зарплату практиканту платить власник автомайстерні. Згодом
ці видатки йому враховують під час щорічної сплати податків.
Амеру зараз 35 років. В Іраку він вже працював автомеханіком,
ремонтував як легкові, так і вантажні авто на фірмі у батька,
тож хисту і досвіду у нього було достатньо і Амер одразу знайшов
спільну мову з власником СТО.
У Німеччині багато школярів влітку намагаються влаштуватися
на практику, аби зсередини пізнати спеціальність, яка припала до душі,
отримати перший досвід і йти в училище вже з навичками.
Друзі, ви лише подивіться: це справжній рай для 13-15-річних хлопців.
Їм тут дозволяють робити все.
Просто якийсь тракторний балет!
На моїх очах в тюки за годину зібрали всю люцерну з цього поля.
Я під враженням від вправності молоді. Людям у кадрі -
від 13-ти до 19-ти років. Все зробили самі без нагляду власника господарства.
Конрад Кессель - найстарший. Він наступного року закінчує навчання
в училищі на електрика. У нього домовленість з батьком-фермером:
лише здобувши кваліфікацію електрика, зможе піти навчатися на фермера.
Зараз поки навчаюся вдома, а наступного року хочу почати
професійне навчання на фермера.
Ось тут угорі видно, скільки тюків ми напресували за сьогодні : 30 штук.
Тут можна налаштувати розмір тюка: один метр 25. Тут - скільки у нас обертів сітки. Три наразі.
Права на водіння трактора у мене вже три роки. Зараз мені 19 років,
їх можна робити з 16-ти. А взагалі ще раніше я їздив удома, в дворі,
скільки себе пам'ятаю.
Я - Єнс Вельх, мені 15 років. У моїх батьків вдома також є велике
сімейне фермерське господарство. Наступного року влітку я міг би
почати профтехнавчання.
Мені 16 років. Мені ще два роки вчитися у школі, потім я два роки
навчатимусь на фермера. А потім я би хотів йти в університет.
Різниця в тому, що після училища можна вести власне господарство,
а після університету я вже зможу консультувати інших.
У цих сільських хлопців і дівчини вдома є трактори, тож кожен з них
вчився з дитинства. Фермер - власник цього господарства -
несе відповідальність за усіх практикантів. Він дозволяє їм їздити
на тракторі на полі і навколо попри юний вік, бо перевірив їхні навички водіння.
Тим, у кого немає прав, не дозволено виїжджати на дороги міського значення.
Попри таку молодь, охочу до робітничих професій, десятки тисяч
місць для навчання щороку залишаються незайнятими.
Німецькому ринку бракує фахівців передусім у сфері металообробки,
електроніки та мехатроніки. Є цілий інститут, який вивчає  проблеми училищ.
Ну, що ж, друзі, я приїхав до дослідницького інституту, у якому
знають все про професійно-технічне навчання у Німеччині,
і мене зустрічає експерт, пан Віхерт.
Пані та панове, ласкаво прошу до Федерального інституту професійно-технічної освіти!
Міхаель Віхерт 26 років досліджує профтехосвіту. Він ділився
німецьким досвідом по всьому світу і вивчав інші системи. Я цікавлюсь
у нього, які професії будуть найбільш затребуваними у ФРН у найближчі роки.
Постійно зростає попит на IT-спеціалістів. Що також цікаво,
у період з 2030-го до 2040 року у сфері соціальних послуг
та охорони здоров'я буде створено 500 тисяч нових робочих місць.
За словами фахівця, найбільш непристосовані до ринку праці
системи профтехосвіти, де і теорію, і практику вивчають лише
у самому училищі - це, зокрема, пострадянські країни. А в Японії
навпаки, каже Віхерт, професійній освіті підприємство навчає дуже
вузькоспеціалізовано, так що учень зможе працювати згодом лише там,
де вчився. Натомість німецька дуальна система орієнтується на потреби учня.
Чиста дуальна система освіти - в Австрії, Ліхтенштейні, Швейцарії
та Німеччині. У часи великих фінансових або економічних криз
у цих країнах було найменше безробіття серед молоді,
і це суттєвий показник.
Тим часом наш герой Амер Аль Хафаджі завершив ремонт і отримав вердикт керівника практики.
Він був уважним, усе перевірив. Наразі виглядає дуже добре!
Друзі, пишіть, шо ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину,
і я обов'язково про це розповім в наступній серії. Побачимось!